oh you know it's ah six nine signing a
ten million dollar deal that's real bow
you think that I feel like people just
tweet that [ __ ] just to get traction I
mean Pro it's who cares maybe it is real
on who even cares million dollars Oh has
the label even have that much money you
know they have like yeah him trippy red
and like two other artists yeah I'm
black there no it's ten no oh it's ten K
that's right projects I thought it was
um thought it was Alamo now yeah true
yeah good good point that's a lot of
[ __ ] money they said to they see
signed for ten million dollars but
aren't they like a subsidiary of someone
big maybe you know yeah it's Luther or
some [ __ ] but even then like they give
them a budget they don't give them
that's true infinite money yeah so is
this mean he's definitely getting out of
prison uh who knows I think he's gonna
get out of prison and what if he becomes
like the next like Tony Robbins I'm
saying okay you imagine like just like
he becomes like a like a religious
motivational speaker and his the premise
of everything is him telling the truth
once I found the light I understand it
was like once I found a light right yeah
I was so caught up in like billboard and
like charting and all that I forgot like
there's so much more to life than like
selling records cuz I conquered that
[ __ ] yeah I did now I want to conquer
the hardest thing which is a
relationship with Jesus Christ and you
can learn of all about my journey on my
new album the truth will always win
stupid stupid stupid true the truth
[Laughter]
he's gonna say he's gonna sound hard as
hell rapping about people and saying
they should snitch more yeah he's gonna
be the anti camera and he's gonna be the
the pro snitchin radder yeah my homie
snitches snitch it
[ __ ] get freedom that'll be his
t-shirt snitches get to live real life
snitch more stupid his first single is
gonna be like tell on them that's good
that's good that's really good
I'm up in the precinct we Telangana I
didn't even do my voice hurts I can't I
can't go full stupid just confessing
everything yeah there's way too much
yeah what if you took taking the blame
for homies what if that's how good of a
dude I am what if he just tells so much
they get tired of how much to the truth
he's telling ya it's like day three and
them in the courtroom and they're like
all right Daniel what else do you want
to tell us today I was molested oh I was
in fourth grade I found my dad as a
playboy enough and I [ __ ] on one of
the pages please please back I was so
sure the defendant tired please and I
don't know if he ever retires the ended
but there was my dried come on it and I
don't know it was pretty stupid
[Laughter]
you know what you're going back to jail
too much too much truth there is too
much there was such a thing as too much
yeah bro it's I mean dude it's exactly
what you know everyone thought it was
gonna be he's gonna you know he's the
whole oh yeah they backstab me and my
girlfriend's a cloud chaser and that's
already working mm-hmm it's already
working
yeah oh yeah he's gonna be huge when he
gets out of prison and a pop out you
think 80% of his listeners cared that he
snitch they probably don't even know
that he went to jail their part is
waiting for his next release honestly I
mean they know you went to jail but like
I don't think they even give a [ __ ]
about the gravity of the situation I
guarantee you there's like a million
people that listen to his music that
don't know that he went to jail yeah I
mean that's just true it was a monthly
listeners that I bet you at some high
let's get the over-under I'm saying over
two mil I'm gonna say eight million to
him twelve oh my [ __ ] god
he's huge man Fifi has a half a billion
place Bibi has 385 million
well [ __ ] has a hundred and ninety
million Kylie has a hundred and ninety
eight million malla has 140 I feel like
such an idiot saying all these titles
malwa Kiki Fifi I'm a baby or I look at
like young bands now cuz he's on house
arrest young bands is yeah I believe so
something like that
you know bands you know I was read one
point nine million damn damn this fool
got 12 million monthly listeners from
jail bro what's whine wml yet is he in
jail yeah bro is he in jail no I know
but it like he's in jail forever yeah 12
million he has he has 12 million yeah
I'll go on to jail is the [ __ ] move
let's [ __ ] that I didn't say there yeah
that's a look yeah credibly ignorant yep
you know [ __ ] record execs and [ __ ]
or like what how could how could we get
you in there for just like three months
that's what they do is skinny from the
nine yeah how can we get you in there
for three months for kidnapping it's a
little just a little sentence just
kidnap somebody that's all we're so
don't like beat them up you can rough
them up a little bit stop my trunk
[ __ ] them around a little bit what's a
little response tops what's a little
sentence just a little something we
could get you in for kidnapping is such
a stupid yeah yeah kidnapping so whack
never so dumb bro such a dumb charge how
do you more like when I when I say when
I hear kidnap I just picture like the
old-fashioned blindfolding talk awesome
in a car definitely not like that but
why is it why is a kidnapping if you
take adults no saying this and [ __ ]
damn there's some third ice [ __ ] right
there it's like good point yeah you're
free hey that's my defense your honor
[ __ ] my client kidnap he's not if the
if the was the other one the offense
how can my defendant be guilty of
kidnapping when the offense is an adult
why do you have a Mike he came and she
was so dumb i'ma have to give it to you
how genius that is all right all right
lawyer students get in the comments let
us know what why is kidnapped well
historically ok federal case 1793 Corbin
versus Dallas
[Music]